thank you guys so much for joining me
actually I'm joining you here oh my
goodness thanks for having us thanks for
coming here this is so exciting so you
guys want to do a quick little intro for
everyone to know how to set the stage
here for us all I'm Cayenne um I work on
the worldwide product marketing team
here at Apple for the iPhone hi I'm Arun
Mathias I'm responsible for our wireless
software here at Apple so this is super
exciting because this year with the
iPhone 14 you guys announced this new
satellite technology how does this
actually work and how is this going to
benefit people sure well I'll start and
a room feel free to chime in as you know
when you need help you need help
wherever you are and with the emergency
SOS via satellite capability we created
this groundbreaking service on all
iPhone 14 models to allow the iPhone
that you have with you in your pocket
all the time to connect directly to a
satellite and get you help when you're
off the grid now of course the satellite
connectivity was a key part of this and
we saw that as important to allow Apple
to expand our offerings as far as safety
features and now satellite connectivity
is important because even though ground
cellular connectivity has improved over
the years there's still some places such
as national parks or winding roads where
cell towers don't quite reach yet and
maybe in most cases these limitations
are okay but when there's an emergency
that can be a problem and so we work to
bring this capability to the iPhone 14
models that you have with you all the
time and you know we're really excited
because it's it's coming really soon
it's coming November 15th to the U.S and
Canada and in fact we're going to be
rolling out to four new regions next
month with the UK Ireland France and
Germany so we're really excited it's
going to be included for two years free
starting with the activation of your
iPhone 14. we can't wait for people to
be able to use it I think this is
incredible because my sister and I we
used to hike so much and we would go off
the grid into these places and it was
really scary so then I ended up going
and getting a satellite phone and it's
this big chunky device and then I would
forget to pay the bill for it then I was
like wait a minute this isn't actually
working when I need it and just to know
that something that I do have with me
always is something that could
potentially save your life so now when
you're actually using this so what does
that kind of look like so say my sister
are out and I either fall or we realize
that we're lost and we need help so how
does that all work yeah so our aim is to
make this as simple and really familiar
for you today with your phone if you
want to call for help call 9-1-1 you can
attempt to make a call to 9-1-1 or in
some places you can send a text to 911.
now that's in some parts of the US not
not everywhere but in a lot of parts of
the US and so our goal with the
experience was to really make it so that
if you went to make that phone call to
9-1-1 your iPhone will try its best to
make that phone call it will try and get
on any available carrier if I cannot
find any carrier because you're out out
in the middle of nowhere it will now
give you an option to be able to use the
satellite to send an emergency SOS via
the satellite from a user perspective
it's it's right there the option shows
up when when you need it and once you
hit on that button it'll kick you into
the experience so the phone obviously
knows when you don't have connections so
you're saying if I actually needed help
I call 9-1-1 it'll automatically connect
me to satellites yeah so when you call
9-1-1 it will realize that it's not able
to actually make a phone call so it'll
give you an option on the screen now to
actually text message with 9-1-1 via the
satellite and something I thought that
was so cool that you guys were doing is
there's this compression algorithm so
that you're making the file size really
small so that's actually able to reach
the satellites because I think that's a
misconception that a lot of people don't
understand like you're communicating
with satellites very far in the sky that
you really cannot see so how does that
all work yeah that's a great point you
know that as you mentioned the
satellites are moving really fast it's
like 15 000 miles per hour 800 miles
above Earth We're creating this
interface that Arun described that
really allows you to get connected
really easily and Arun can speak to the
short text compression algorithm but one
of the things even ahead of that is we
created this questionnaire that surface
is the most common questions during a
real emergency so that you can very
quickly tap and select those answers and
we can press that and send that up much
more efficiently than having to do all
of that through back and forth texting
the amount of data that we can send is
fairly minimal because it needs to get
up to 800 miles above and so we we built
this questionnaire so we can really
reduce the amount of data that needs to
be sent and this tux compression
algorithm by
identifying that a user is actually
communicating with 9-1-1 for the purpose
of trying to trying to get help we we
trained an algorithm where we basically
trained trained the algorithm using
words that the user naturally would use
with 9-1-1 when you think about
satellites you kind of think about like
a satellite hanging off the side of your
roof or something like that like I think
that's what a lot of people's kind of
misconception of what a satellite really
is in the demos I was like so you have
to like move around and find the
satellite so how does that all work so
it's kind of stepping back as you
mentioned at the start a satellite
device today has a huge antenna often
protruding out of it right and of course
that wouldn't work for iPhone so we had
to design something that would work
within the constraints of iPhone support
all the different capabilities that
iPhone already supports so it's a
communication with the satellite is uh
is is built in a way that we identify
where how a user can kind of Orient
towards the satellite but they hold it
in a very natural way it's not like they
need to be reaching this thing towards
the sky you don't actually have to stand
like this our goal with experience is to
give you very clear guidance in the
moment and so with both Visual and
haptic feedback it lets you know you may
need to turn a little bit and then
you're holding it in this natural way
it'll show you when you're connected and
once you're connected it's in a very
familiar messaging thread so so once you
fill out that question that puts you in
a familiar messaging thread just like
you're sending text messages back and
forth and so you have these relay
centers all set up now what was that
process like kind of setting up these
centers to kind of intercept this new
way of communicating for emergencies so
first of all a lot of emergency service
providers don't accept text messages off
the bat some of them do in which cases
when you're texting you'll communicate
directly with those emergency service
providers but for the many that don't we
had to set up these relay centers and
build out this ground infrastructure so
that we had highly trained Specialists
there who basically take your text
message in and they place a phone call
to Emergency Services on your behalf and
they will relay your conversation back
and forth in a very efficient manner and
then to the user it's the same
experience either way what's happening
in the back end is what's different but
we're going to get you that help and
connect you with the Emergency Services
providers and working with also the new
Apple watch which I'm obsessed with how
is this all working with like crash
attack fall detect because what if I'm
in a car accident and you don't have
cell reception so how does that gonna
that sort of the same sort of technique
yeah so once uh the the phone watch
detects that you've been in a crash it
would uh again try and call 9-1-1 if
it's unable to call 9-1-1 it will then
now use this capability to try and get
the message out via the satellite in
that situation the phone actually
probably is does not have a clear view
of the sky and might be between the
seats or in the trunk so we keep the
data extremely small in that situation
and we have a really good conference
that we'll still be able to get that
message out and get you help something
else that my friends and my family we
all use is find my so I have find my on
for like all my friends especially for
my mom because she doesn't even have to
ask where I am at any time we go out on
a hike we always let her know when we're
leaving but now are they going to be
able to see using the satellite sharing
locations yeah so one of one of the
things we we realized was this
technology could probably be used in a
situation like that as well when you're
off on that hike Findlay is no longer
updating your location so now we give
the users an option to be able to
manually update their location so for
example if they get to the campsite or
certain periods that they want to keep
their loved ones up to date on where
they are they can now manually do that
and it will guide them through getting
the location updated this is great my
mom's going to be so excited now but I
feel like this is going to help so many
people so how do you see this kind of
really changing the future of kind of
Safety and Security for people sure well
as you know we've been developing safety
features over the year we had fall
detection on Apple watch the regular
emergency SOS and crash detection and
now this capability through satellite
and we're being really thoughtful about
how all the learnings that we've had
through these other safety features and
really being able to build upon and
expand it in a way that never before was
possible before we built in the
satellite connectivity and so that was a
piece that we were pretty excited about
being able to bring this in but as you
see it requires not just hey we're going
to connect to satellites but it requires
us to do all this custom work on the
iPhone Hardware side the work on the
software side with the algorithms and
the connectivity but also how we connect
to the satellites themselves that are
very complex infrastructure that are
moving high in the sky and then building
out that sophisticated ground
infrastructure go with it and all along
the way we've been taking learnings from
the past things that we've done and
other connectivity areas of iPhone but
being able to take this to this new
category of safety to bring more users
that additional Peace of Mind of having
the safety features because even though
some people are really great about
learning and paying for these dedicated
satellite devices for a lot of people
they're just like casual weekend hikers
and they may not even realize they're
going to end up off the grid and find
themselves in an emergency situation and
so now having this on the iPhone that
you're going to have to take your video
to take your photos it just brings you
that additional layer of safety and of
course that peace of mind yeah and the
satellite phones were great except like
you said most of the time when you need
it you don't have it with you so like
every time I was actually on a hike or
even just in a remote location where you
would actually need this you don't have
it so I guess going back to the software
and what does that whole process look
like I guess from kind of start to
finish saying I'm out there and I need
to use it is there anything that we
would need to know going into it or it's
just it'll automatically start working I
was going to just remind people they
should update their medical ID because
that's also something we send up in
addition to the questionnaire which can
include critical information like your
age if you have any allergies or any
medication if you choose to fill that
out and so that's also a very quick way
to get that up there so that's something
you can do ahead of time so that when
you're in an emergency all that works
effectively so now does this alert my
medical people that I have kind of
listed like my emergency contacts and
then also go to the the relay centers as
well if you do have your emergency
contacts set up it can you do have the
option to choose to notify your
emergency contacts during that
questionnaire that you send up to the
emergency services providers and so what
will happen is if they're on iOS 16.1 or
later they will actually get an alert
that says hey that someone they know is
has had an emergency event and using
emergency SOS via satellite in which you
like to see the transcript and then
they'll be able to see a live transcript
of your conversation two-way with that
emergency service provider or relay
Center including your location and the
nature of your emergency so does this
pop up like a separate app or is it
basically just an iMessage so like I
would be texting a friend but now I'm
texting for help yeah just an iMessage
just like you would text a friend you'd
have a message thread with 9-1-1 and
then your emergency contacts will
actually be able to see that live
transcript that Cayenne mentioned and
that we built the live transcript
because your emergency contact can't
really contact you at that point right
you're not available for to receive a
phone call or send a message to them so
this keeps them informed on on what's
Happening is there a way to let the
emergency responders know once someone
has arrived like how does that all work
when kind of the situation goes down and
then you're okay well you can see the
the transcripts so you would be able to
see for example if they said okay help
is on the way so you'd be able to follow
alongside
um the same time as the emergency yeah
and in many cases you'll actually
continue that emergency session with
until the actual responder shows up that
right and so they'd see that all the way
through to that so obviously these
satellites have been up there for a
really long time so what was it like
kind of I don't know I guess wrangling
the satellites figuring out how this all
is going to work well certainly I mean
there's a sophisticated network of
satellites that are already in orbit
they have regulatory approval they've
been built with redundancy capacity and
so it's a really reliable infrastructure
that we had and so we did an additional
level of technical work both on the
satellite side as well as on device side
and how we connected but it's already a
really great robust solution that allows
us to to bring this capability to so
many people uh you know pretty much on
November 15th when it when it starts go
going live one of the other things that
we considered was you know we looked at
a band when we picked the technology we
picked a single band that allowed it to
work in many places around the world so
that even if you are traveling let's say
to another location where we eventually
enable this or vice versa you'll be able
to have access to the same Emergency
Services capability via satellite yeah
and so it was really important to us to
actually use a satellite constellation
that was actually fully mature and built
out and so as you identified the
challenge became how do we make the
iPhone actually be able to interact with
this thing that's already launched and
and up there and been up there for a
long time and is mature and so we had to
make the the necessary Hardware
modifications to allow us to optimize
that communication back and forth and
then build an entirely new communication
stack that included a whole new waveform
and all the layers above a custom link
layer custom networking layer and so
really really very very much custom for
this purpose and and be able to put the
system together it's really wild just
kind of picturing all of this and even
getting a demo of it so like how does my
phone know that it's pointing to a
satellite like that's just it's so wild
like I can't really wrap my mind around
it yeah and so given that that these
satellites are orbiting we actually have
information on the phone for it to be
able to know what satellites it should
be expecting to see at that point in
time and then also it's going to see
multiple of them it's going to know that
there are multiple of that being able to
identify which one's the best one and as
it's guiding the user to possibly turn a
little bit it might identify that one
another one might be the better one or
have a better
strength for it to be able to connect so
it'll guide the user and in a very
simple way so the user really doesn't
really need to know any of this that it
just tells them that they need to turn a
little bit and then give them clear
indication that they're connected to the
satellite it's really cool and it's such
amazing technology and I feel like so
lucky to be able to be in this time
where that's going to be helping so many
people's lives hopefully I never have to
use it but just knowing that that sort
of is in my pocket or in my purse or on
a high with me just gives me that peace
of mind so now we're joined with Mike
welcome thank you yeah so my name is
Mike treela I lead the satellite
connectivity group at Apple that's
helped enable these new great amazing
features on iPhone 14. so how did you
kind of go about figuring out which
satellites you were going to choose like
how does this all work well we partnered
with a great company in global star
Global star has been offering mobile
satellite services for decades and we
utilize their satellites because they
have some really unique characteristics
one of them being they have a single
Global frequency that is approved for
use for satellites to communicate to
mobile devices like iPhone 14s
regulatory approval for these satellites
has been key in sort of implementing and
being able to launch this service this
fall I think the cool thing is obviously
you know when you're using Apple
products like they just work if you're
out and you need this you want it to
work so choosing the satellite partner I
think was you know obviously a key
component to that for you I mean working
from Hardware to software to to these
satellites up in the sky like what was
the most challenging part of all of that
well really these satellites were not
designed to operate with iPhones you
know they were purposely designed to
work with dedicated satellite
communication devices that have large
bulky antennas which wouldn't have
worked for iPhone so we really needed to
develop new technology optimize the
iPhone optimize the satellites to really
make this link possible so on the phone
we enabled the dedicated frequencies
that were approved for satellite usage
as well as on the satellite we work
closely with globalstar to implement a
new high power mode that allow us to
sort of maximize the opportunity for
connection with the iPhone but to do so
within the regulatory limits so how do
you scale this because there's so many
iPhones there's obviously only so many
satellites that you can put into orbit
yeah the the scale that iPhone brings
obviously was a big question that we
wanted to make sure that we were going
to deliver a high quality service so we
built a very sophisticated geolocation
model that defined where all of our
users would be when they're off grid
we've got we were able to build this
model using Anonymous private Centric
data from our current phones with that
model we were able to Overlay the
network behavior of the satellite to
ensure that we had enough capacity both
for those everyday usages as well as
those peak times where the users are
going to be needing to get a help that's
really cool so basically you know where
there's kind of like the dead zones and
kind of already had those sort of marked
out is that kind of what that means yeah
we have a we have a general idea
obviously we want to maintain privacy
and be anonymous but you know we do want
to know where we expect to have hot
spots and will the satellite Network
serve it and we've done an extraordinary
amount of testing to be able to ensure
that these satellites are ready to go to
provide help so obviously like so much
went into this so how was that kind of
working you know with so many different
pieces of technology and new technology
to kind of work into the new iPhone 14.
first of all I'd love to just say how
great it was for all the teams coming
together to collaborate on this because
as you can see you know we have a couple
of people here but there's really tons
of people behind them and all the work
that had to happen on the software the
hardware the infrastructure side but we
also have to look at you know what else
is the iPhone used for right we don't
want to put like giant bulky antenna to
the point made or else you wouldn't want
to carry that around and you wouldn't
want to use that as your everyday phone
so we wanted to make it work within the
beautiful design of iPhone have it
coexist in harmony with the other
connectivity features like Wi-Fi and
Bluetooth and all the 5G bands and
everything else that your phone has to
do for you every day and that was part
of a lot of the hard work but then at
the end of the day as sud is just a very
simple interface and a very simple
experience to guide our users to be able
to use the Emergency Services a very
super simple interface for a very
complex problem to solve
kind of looking at this all now that
it's out there like what are you most
proud of I think with iPhone 14 we're
taking satellite connectivity which has
kind of been for dedicated users and
we're bringing it to a whole new user
base people that are you know find
themselves occasionally off grid not
expecting to be off-grid and now we've
got this new technology that's really
going to be out there available for all
of iPhones i-14 users yeah I think just
satellite connectivity felt like
something that was so futuristic and far
off that was not attainable to anyone
and now pretty much everyone can have a
satellite in their pocket it's really
really cool well thank you so much is
there anything else that you want to add
about this new feature coming out well
we're really excited to have it come out
today I know millions of users will have
that benefit pretty soon and so we're
just looking forward to getting it out
there and hopefully helping people when
they need it so now is there a demo that
people can try this out or like how can
they actually see if this is going to
work there is a demo you can do that
ahead of time without a real emergency
you just want to go out to a clear Open
Sky because that's how the future works
best but you'll actually be able able to
connect directly with the real satellite
in the same way you would in a real
emergency and will guide you through
that intuitive interface just so that
you can familiarize yourself a little
bit with how that's going to work and so
that in a real emergency you'll be more
ready that's great I think everyone
should definitely try that out just to
be prepared because I feel like when
you're actually in the moment when there
is an emergency you don't want to be
figuring something out like that but I
think what's great is you guys have made
the interface so simple which is so
impressive the way that you were able to
compress the data to make it super small
to be able to get up to the satellites
that's something else that's kind of
interesting because I think people don't
understand how long it takes for data to
actually transfer up to satellites do
you want to talk a little bit about like
what that actually is like the
communications actually with the iPhone
and the satellite is very similar to
what you would expect terrestrial on
grid we built and worked closely with
globalstar to put the custom protocol
stack not only in the iPhone but we put
an apple proprietary radio system in
each of globalstar's ground stations
that enabled we had the highest quality
communication link between the iPhone
and the satellite Network well thank you
guys so much for joining me this was
really fun and I can't wait for everyone
to check it out thank you thank you so
much
[Music]